what i want to do in this video is think
about how my blue hydroxide ion right
here might react with the various
molecules that i have drawn in yellow
and what i want to focus on first is how
these yellow molecules are different so
right over here i have a carbon bonded
to three hydrogens and a bromine atom
and so this right over here is bromo
bromo methane
bromo methane but the important thing to
think about in consideration of what
we're going to talk about in this video
is the fact that the carbon other than
the fact that it's other than the fact
that it's it's bonded to the bromo group
it only is bonded to other hydrogens so
we could call this a methyl carbon
methyl
methyl
carbon
what about the carbon in this case right
this is bromoethane
well over here this carbon it's
definitely bonded to the bromo group but
it's also bronze it's also bonded to
another carbon it's bonded to this
carbon right over here
so in this case we would call this a
primary
primary carbon it is bonded to one other
carbon
well what about this one over here well
you see immediately it is bonded to two
carbons this carbon and this carbon
right over here so we would call this a
secondary carbon
secondary carbon and this carbon right
over here is bonded to three other
carbons one two three so we call this a
tertiary carbon
tertiary carbon and as we'll see through
the course of this video the type of
carbon we're dealing with how many other
carbons we're bonded with will dictate
what type of a reaction might occur and
how fast that reaction might occur
so let's go to this situation right over
here this hydroxide ion is a reasonable
nucleophile so let me write this down
this is our nucleophile it's going to be
the nucleophile in every in every
scenario that we're talking about and we
talked just as a review nucleophile is
something that is seeking a nucleus or i
guess another way you could think about
it it's looking to give away its
electron
and similarly you can imagine this right
over here this bromine it could be a
pretty good leaving group it's not it
doesn't mind accepting an electron
so and i'm not going to talk too much
about the solvent we'll just assume that
the solvent is appropriate for this type
of reaction you could imagine you could
imagine that the nucleophile right over
here this hydroxide ion might want to
give
give one of its electrons to this methyl
carbon and right as that is happening
right as that is happening
the bromine can take
one it can take back an electron or take
an electron i should say and become a
bromide ion
now we've seen this type of reaction
before we call this sn2
we would call this let me do this in let
me do this in purple we would call this
an sn2 reaction why is it sn2 it's
substitution we're sub we're
substituting the bromide the bromine
with the hydroxide
why is it n well n for nucleophile and
why is it two well two is because in one
step we have both of the reactants are
reacting or another way to think about
the rate determining step involves both
of the reactants in sn1 you have one
thing leave and then the other thing
comes back it happens in different steps
here the rate determining step both of
the reactants are reacting fair enough
and for the sake of this video because
we're really com we want to compare what
reaction happens and how fast it happens
here we'll say that this is happening
quite fast
quite
quite fast and we'll see the difference
here is how easy it is for the
nucleophile to access the carbon that it
is reacting with here it's very easy for
it to access it there's nothing getting
in its way
now let's look at this scenario right
over here well once again we can imagine
we can imagine our nucleophile wanting
to give away one of its electrons to the
carbon and then the leaving group taking
an electron away and becoming a bromide
ion so once again we are going to have
an sn
an sn2 reaction but in this case it's
going to happen a little bit slower than
what we saw in this in the case right
here over the left why is that well this
this other ch3 this is much larger than
just a hydrogen would be and so it's
kind of blocking the nucleophile from
approaching from certain directions
remember all of what we do in organic
chemistry and chemistry it seems like
these neat and clean reactions where
everything knows what to do but these
aren't intelligent creatures
they're just randomly bumping into each
other and if you have this big ch3
sitting here that's going to block the
nucleophile from approaching from that
direction in this case right over here
hydrogen is a very small atom it's not
going to really block as much as this
entire ch3 is going to and because of
that we're going to still have the sn2
reaction but it's going to occur a
little bit slower so maybe we'll call
this quite fast and then we'll call this
a bit slower a bit slower a bit slower
but still
reasonably but still fast but still fast
and obviously i'm not giving you exact
numbers but we're talking about relative
rates of reaction
now let's go over here where we have a
secondary carbon well same principle
applies we can still have the sn2
reaction our nucleophile gives an
electron
our leaving group takes an electron so
we're still going to have an sn2
reaction but now we're being blocked by
more things we have a ch3 up here and we
have a ch3 down here so this reaction is
going to occur this reaction is going to
be slow
now finally let's look at this situation
in this situation we are really blocking
the nucleophile from being able to get
to the carbon you have a ch3 over here
ch3 over here ch3 is over here each of
these are going to be much bigger than
the hydrogens in this case so in this
situation it's blocking it so much it's
blocking i guess you could view the
nucleophile's attack on that carbon it's
blocking it from so many different
directions that you actually will not
have an sn2 reaction right over here so
let me write no
no
sn2
right over here
and this whole phenomenon what we're
trying to talk about in this video where
the reaction is determined by
essentially the how the shape of the of
the molecule is and what might be
getting in its way we call this
phenomenon
we call it steric hindrance
steric
steric
hindrance
and what does it mean to hinder
something it means to kind of get in the
way or make it seem like it's or make it
harder for it to happen and so in this
case these the the ch3 groups are large
they're hindering the nucleophile from
attacking the carbon and steric just
means kind of the the three-dimensional
shape of it the three-dimensional shape
of it is keeping it from is keeping it
from re or the three-dimensional shape
is what is doing the hindering and
that's what we see in all of these cases
now the last thing you might be thinking
about is well why can't why can't it
attack from this direction why can't the
nucleophile go from that direction and
that actually is possible in an sn1
reaction an sn1 reaction the leaving
group leaves and so there's kind of an
opening for the nucleophile to come in
later but in this case you actually have
your leaving group that's in the way
it's going to block your nucleophile
from attacking from that direction so
when we talk about sn2 reactions the
nucleophile is going is coming from the
different the nucleophile is coming from
the opposite side from which the leaving
group is actually leaving